orange Frank just walked by our
broadcast table just prior to tip and I
said our you know guys helped to get in
front you know progressing he's like yes
moving in the right direction nice drive
there but it's like can they stay
healthy yeah or something maybe a lot of
work you like this too much man I'm
worried about you
thank you
of course appreciate y'all
George sneaks open on the inbound
[Applause]
and train man
oh excuse me I'm sorry Terence man
oh nice look that's a beauty that story
on the backside this is going to get two
looks it's that good chiante George up
high in transition it's been a
fast-paced game
I'll tell you what the ball is changing
sides very well by both teams George off
glass
turned it over
Deontay George flying private
[Applause]
Bowden for three blocked by George a
little atonement at the other end
[Applause]
[Music]
Hibachi drives Baseline on Thomas
George for three rips cord flippers in a
little bit of a scramble mode here
down by 14. George with a crossover in
the mini is pure he's starting to heat
up a little I think Lowry Martin had
talked about that having a huge impact
on his experience well that'll make you
smile butter from the corner
you know Dante Jones has thrown a bunch
of different defenses George
[Applause]
George
[Music]
that hit like a stimulus check